do you do a lot of podcasts
I've done them I wouldn't say I do them
on the rag
yeah
you just do it like when your friends
ask like your comedian friends ask you
to yeah yeah and be a guest on them and
stuff are we is this now like yeah is
the Hans Kim podcast started or like
yeah it's been going on for about 20
seconds now but like you don't do like
hi everyone welcome this week to Hans
cam I'm gonna be at Fort Wayne Indiana
and welcome please come out link tree
Dash DJ Hans Kim
uh Kanye West is in the news any
thoughts on Kanye West
oh wait are you asking me yeah
this is the most nonchalant podcast I've
ever been on I uh uh do you do you want
to introduce me or yeah this is Chris
troney yeah
it's from Chicago
he uh supports Kanye West
that's not true that's not true
the old Kanye for sure ah yeah like
Jesus Walks yeah or uh graduation
Edwards in Paris
yeah sure
that's a great song
uh I don't know I it's kind of we talked
about this before we started recording
it's like
he's kind of just
creating his own demise it's sad like
yeah
like he has he was a billionaire and now
I think they were saying because he's no
longer
joined up with Reebok like or Adidas
whichever one like
he may lose billions in valuation right
because like no longer going to make
that shoe and sell it and it's just sad
yeah there's so much of it is
speculation people used him to bet be
like oh he's like a stock and now right
so much of uh Financial wealth is
determined by like society and what we
determine is worth it's evaluation yes
see also GameStop yeah
he's uh he's definitely tanking now I
mean I'm glad like it'd be concerning if
he was getting even more popular which I
think is totally a possibility yeah yeah
I I don't know it's like but do you
think he can come back from this yes
I think so I think it could be a great
thing if he came back I think I'd give a
lot of people like and make a lot of
people happy if he did it yeah but do
you think that like with his mental
health being where it's at right now
that the fact that he's willing to do
say these outrageous things and not and
double down on them because there's so
much ego and pride there right like do
you think he's do you think so do you
I think my question is do you think he's
able to like do you think he really
could like mentally yeah that he
mentally has enough Acumen to kind of
get it together and Salvage that yeah I
mean the way that he's [ __ ] up is
still useful it just seems like a
child's error yeah I feel like if he
matures and grows up
that he could definitely figure it out
yeah
yeah
um but yeah I mean I think it'd be a
great Arc because like the things that
he's saying are so wrong yeah like
there's no way that he's gonna continue
believing this yeah and the the
catharsis that we would feel to have it
yeah fix this [ __ ] would be we would all
breathe a sigh of relief yeah thank God
yeah we were right there for a second
yeah but I also think like some of these
guys they they double down you know what
I'm saying like
like like they don't want to admit that
they're wrong they're like the
who are like some of the awful politics
it's like a Donald Trump almost where
like you don't you wanna you wanna find
your tribe that validates you you don't
want to admit you were wrong you know
but I don't know I think that he doesn't
give a [ __ ] about other people's opinion
enough yeah where he's gonna be like
well I don't really care about fighting
a cult following right I'd rather just
uh live the best life for myself yeah
part of that is not [ __ ] on the Jews
unnecessarily yeah yeah
yeah well wasn't it even in the
interview like I think someone like
Charlemagne was like trying to call him
out and his retort was not like oh
you're right I might be wrong it was
more like I could say whatever I want
and Adidas and Reebok won't
drop me or what what's issue I better
get it right as he does it's Adidas yeah
he's like an Adidas won't dry it's like
it's like that's I no wonder him and
Trump were friends like they've got that
same crazy like I'd rather be
like wrong and have fans then admit you
know it's like such an egomaniac that
doesn't want to admit that they were
wrong yeah
it's uh it makes me respect Trump more
to be like oh this is how Trump could
have ended up but he is holding it
together a lot better than cotton hands
yeah I I suppose this makes you respect
Trump more yeah
but maybe I could have gone way worse I
don't know man but I like that he went
crazy because like before he said all
the Jew stuff he was talking about white
lives matter yeah so the talking about
that juice stuff really
delegitimized his white lives matter
sounds yeah
yeah because at first it just looked
like at first when this all started it
just looked like an absolute blunder in
the fashion world
and now it looks like a complete
meltdown really yeah just a meltdown but
like I hate to say this as a fan of old
Kanye like I don't know if he has the
call it what you will the the fortitude
the the humility to
get it together and kind of like do a
make a call Button like come back from
this do you know what I'm sometimes I
think when people are gone it's sort of
like watching an old overweight boxer
like you're never gonna shed those
pounds you're never gonna get back in
shape you're never gonna
contend for the title again you know
what I'm saying yeah like this could be
a death blow I mean there were a lot
less impactful death blows to careers
like Sinead O'Connor yeah uh ripping up
the picture of the poem yeah
um
yeah back in the day when people
actually respected institutions like
that like it was in America too no not
not a lot of Catholics in America but
they were still like upwards for
Catholics yeah like religion was very
touchy yeah and it was like she was
right like they were molesting children
and getting away with it I think that's
why she did it yeah yeah I forget her
motivation but like yeah we've seen John
Lennon once said that the Beatles were
bigger than Jesus
you know but see like he got in trouble
for that but he walked it back on like a
talk show he was like look I just meant
that we were popular like I he at least
walked it back and you know he was John
Lennon he was able to still have a
career but like Sinead O'Connor kind of
did another dead deer this is a part of
the podcast is uh
um Hans and I just drives through
Indiana and see where people have killed
deers you know
see the last resting place of animals in
armchairs and um
Yeah well yeah I don't know like Eric
Clapton like it's all coming have you
heard about Eric Clapton no
dude so Eric Clapton like I don't know
Hans Kim's fans cheers in heaven that
well yeah Tears in Heaven like Layla
you know
um it was in cream Derek and the
dominoes like
Eric Clapton like has said some pretty
awful racist stuff over the years you
know well and we're just fighting out
we're just finding out about it and it's
kind of be getting known now like he's
had like meltdowns that concerts were
like he said racist stuff and it's like
is there a theme yeah it's pretty racist
stuff like it kind of something that
keep England White's stuff and you know
immigrants should leave England kind of
stuff
that's English races that's Eric Clapton
saying that not me
uh but it's just so weird it's like but
this is like what we were talking about
earlier it's like
where where are you saying like in the
era of like Elvis like people could
maybe say some horrible stuff a famous
person and we wouldn't know about it
because like not ever like no one would
have their like
you could be Elvis and have a meltdown
at some concert hall in Tennessee and
nothing but if you are you know Justin
Timberlake and you had a meltdown at a
concert hall in Tennessee clip that
and uh everyone has their cell phones do
you know what I'm saying like we'd know
about it in seconds you know
you know plus Michael
like you record like going to the
bathroom at life
so there's just more opportunities
I think what Hans is trying to say
is that you
racist in the old days
this one is good
Kanye needs to put all this energy he's
putting into giving interviews and start
making music with it I don't know why
he's not making music
well I have a theory that
um you know as like the prolific uh
musician that I am
I have a theory that like have you heard
the Tarantino nine movie Theory no so
Quentin Tarantino has a movie like
he's like once you've done any major
director after they've made nine they
actually get bored with filmmaking and
they get bored with
you know like all that stuff they just
get bored like you've made nine right
you've wrote them you've directed them
you do tour and press for them like he's
like kind of boring after a while you
know like and he thinks that most great
filmmakers doesn't matter who
you know Kurosawa whomever Coppola like
start to make some bad stuff so
Tarantino has said something like after
about nine or ten he's like you really
want to retire you know and he said that
he will retire because it's kind of
bored with the genre
and my theory is the same with Kanye
like his
original albums were so well produced
there was like such production like I
mean he had voice over artists and
guests and it was very tight stuff
like with the life of Pablo he's
literally like what should we call this
he's like putting that out on Twitter
yeah and you know it's like what is it
the life of Pablo or like he put the
acronym out there he goes what should
this be and someone wrote the life of
you know it's like
it's like I don't think he cares anymore
like
yeah he's bored it's just like when
you're doing something amazing for so
long it just feels like anything you do
for so long
I think it's it's hard work it's like do
you really want to chase perfectionism
or in his case like does he want to keep
making perfect albums or does he wanna
be a little overweight talk [ __ ] on
radio yeah like when is this over yeah
that's why uh someone like Joe Rogan is
so impressive is because he has that
Zeal and that energy still and it's
he enjoys the pursuit of perfection for
that sake and not just because
uh it's something that he's trying to do
to just survive it's like
it's something that he likes doing yeah
and he's liked it that way from the
beginning yeah
and there's there's something a lot
easier no not no offense to Joe I'm not
talking to you know Joe don't snip this
but like it's a lot easier to just like
you know you turn on a recorder and
you're like let's just talk and do a pod
right I think with music it's kind of
like a good joke there's really it's got
to be worked out you know it's like yeah
music is more emotional right you got to
get your feelings right right and then
like if you feel bad then it's it shows
the music right
yeah
yeah you just can't just put some random
notes together and hope that it works
it's got to be the melody and
everything's kind of and also like with
rap I mean he's rapping and it's got to
sound good and
what's up yeah I mean look how well
polished like
College Dropout was and graduation is a
masterpiece
and Beautiful Dark Twisted Fantasy like
it's one of the greatest albums of all
time run away oh my God you know and um
and then you know imagine putting all
that back breaking work into it and they
truly lived up to the hype but then
oh boy like then you can tell he's a
little bored he's like by the time donda
came out I don't know what did you think
of donda I'm not that familiar with the
yeah the album names
yeah it was like the last one that he
just dropped they're just ridiculous
sorry I saw the documentary and it
seemed like uh it was a lot there was
like a Christian theme to it and
I just feel like a lot of people uh when
they re-achieve uh success
it's yeah it's not interesting to them
anymore because they were doing it to
gain material wealth or social approval
and if they have it and it's like
that uh they were motivated by a
short-term but very potent fuel yeah but
then that fuel corrodes the vessel that
it's in right
well yeah imagine being in pursuit of
just some money and then you have an
insane amount like
like I remember I used to follow Kanye
West on Twitter I don't even know if
he's still on it it was just years ago
and it's like this is years ago he like
put out a tweet he's like watching like
The Dark Knight on his overhead
projector and his condo somewhere like
in New York or something you know
and it's like at the time you probably
thought that was sick you know like oh
dude I'm watching the The Dark Knight on
a Blu-ray
like you know like look at the well and
now it's boring to him you know what I'm
saying like
it's like that's
you know like it's not fascinated by
life anymore now he's just right it
seems like he's sort of like
uh disappointed by the world yeah he's
achieved Mastery over it right he
doesn't respect it anymore right one
he's just [ __ ] all over us he's
giving us our his lowest likes thoughts
but don't you think that that can happen
to anyone when they inherit not inherent
but come into
you know millions of dollars like when
you have well like you can
eat anything you can buy anything you
can see it you can travel just about it
do you know what I'm saying like yeah
there's there's almost like something to
be said about like
being a board millionaire
trust me try me oh
you know
yeah
um yeah I think that uh anyone can do it
but it's like the kind of people that
are become billionaires in a society
that is sort of lost its way and they
don't really know what it's doing or not
I mean maybe if we had a better Society
than Kanye wouldn't
uh disrespect it so much yeah then maybe
he could like you know like tell us
things that uh you know maybe he
wouldn't let his guard down or like
especially since uh I don't know how
hard his life was but I guess like just
because he's black I assume it's hard
but like if if the world treated you
shitty and then you achieve Mastery over
it then you're just gonna be like well
[ __ ] you yeah you had I had to do all
this amazing [ __ ] just so I could get
basic uh decency right right so maybe
like
maybe he wasn't traumatized but his
culture definitely was which I know he
hates
trauma culture but I mean I think it is
a part of it like he's displaying it
like he says he hates it but he's like
the clearest example of it
or it's like this is not a healthy
person yeah I think that an unhealthy
Society produces unhealthy billionaires
yeah
yeah
like you can tell the health of a
ecosystem by the carnivores and the
Predators
and like the best of us this is what we
produce so
we have a lot of flaws yeah yeah
well it's so much of it being based on
image you know
yeah
and for Hans Kim's comedy dates you know
yeah come on and see me yeah this is his
whole hour this is what he does for an
hour you know
yeah
I mean I think that's the thing behind
like all these trans people
is like we only value the most
shallowest simplest things in people
and if you're born not that attractive
you're like well what do I have I mean
at least I could change my gender maybe
there's something interesting about me
just in the physical world and it's like
I don't I don't think that we should be
valuing our physical selves as much as
we do I think we should value our
intellectual selves because that's
what's responsible for sure
all right the best part of human
development is inventions and cars and
right skyscrapers and it's like we're
just trying to Value like how pretty we
are and right how how strong we are and
that's not it's a it's not a good Outlet
like the mind is so much more there that
we could uh delve into and we try to do
that with our bodies and it's just not
our bodies are not that impressive yeah
that's actually why I've always
struggled with sometimes with uh
football because like I'm not you know a
lot of people love football no offense
if you love football but it just sort of
feels like a little bit an extension of
the Roman Coliseum it's the Gridiron on
Sunday yeah and it's a lot of like
that's why I like jokes it's because
they're they can be cerebral I mean some
can be absolutely dumb but like they can
be cerebral and yet funny and illicit
laughter they're clever you know like
yeah you know yeah there's more there
than just
whoa oh yeah like like are you a
football fan no yeah I mean I'm an MMA
fan yeah which is sort of similar but
very yeah MMA there's like a limit to
how much you can enjoy that because at
some point your favorite fighter is
going to get knocked the [ __ ] out so
you're gonna be like wow yeah your
favorite fighter could be a danger it
could be a vegetable yeah that's kind of
funny that's actually kind of neat like
like like it's like teaching kids like
the fragility of life like yeah well
like I was a big fan of that fighter but
then uh they his brain turned to Mush
sorry
that's really morbid yeah yeah it's like
a dog dying yeah
that's how uh yeah my brother once it
hit I think he he had his son and his
dog was already in advanced year she was
like you know in about six to eight
years he'll he'll learn a lesson about
loss
great yeah yeah
because you can't get that soon enough
right
but yeah I mean I think like football
and stuff like that like there's a lot
there's a connection between like
fascist groups and Europe and like
soccer hooligans really yeah like that's
where a lot of uh people recruit from in
fascist organizations because I mean if
that's all you're looking for you know
it's this immediate reaction then it's
going to be like well we can kill the
Jews or we could Institute or we could
root for Arsenal
that's sorry yeah that's kind of funny
well I was gonna be an anti-semi but
then I decided to go for West Ham United
yeah maybe it's rescuing people go Barca
that's funny uh no I I have heard that
like that's the big thing about sports
is it's still tribalism right you're
still you get to identify with people
you get to wear the same Garb you get to
wear the same group and Elk group right
right you can root against something
there's unity and in a mutual hatred
like Packers fans hate Bears fans Bears
fans hate Packers fans you know
every yeah you you enjoy seeing your
enemies be defeated right
uh and it's very zero-sum game right
so I don't think that's very healthy
but yeah I mean if you're training your
Society to just enjoy you know like hits
and
uh violence and you know things like
that then things that are like more
emotional or like you know the more
womenly things like taking care of the
elderly or yeah instituting tort
reformer
things like that aren't going to be
you're just gonna want that immediate
solution right you're gonna want to drop
the hammer right and you know like
maybe the solution isn't to just
eliminate minorities yeah
it'd be so funny if like you know like
on
on like NFL Sunday they've got that
famous music it's like
it's like we cut to someone like white
wiping Grandma's ass
you're like what this is the news this
is the Hans Kim Sunday entertainment
is is like uh vegetables if you sit
through this and I'll give you someone
getting hit really hard right right
right right right if we can get tort
reform you can get a Super Bowl
I don't I think tour reform is sort of
like uh
uh like a right-wing thing because
they're like little people shouldn't be
able to sue corporations I don't know if
tort reform is the best example but yeah
yeah
um yeah I think uh
I think like yeah we need to uh
reward the more like uh more uh
intellectual side of life yeah but how
do you do I mean how do you reverse
America and even and I hate this sort of
beating up America because Europe's
plenty guilty of it too how do you
reverse this sort of like
you know people who just want to like
almost like watch sports and there's
nothing wrong with sports I watch some
sports but it's like it's like you know
like how do you get a society in general
to kind of like
not go extinct with climate change to
educate its people do you know what I'm
saying like I I believe you can have
both yeah but I I don't know the answer
I'm legitimately asking
nearly got a car accident that would
that would have been good
yeah I don't think the phone would have
stayed up yeah I don't think the phone
would have stayed up I would have got
Chris audio though yeah me screaming
that's what it sounds like when
comedians are in tragedies right
um I think uh
war did it for Europe yeah I mean World
War II yeah uh kind of shook Europe and
where they were kind of like scared into
doing the right thing like England lost
its Empire they just lost the sort of
like
desire for that kind of violence yeah so
I think like hitting rock bottom yeah is
something
yeah I think about that a lot the
absolute desolation of Europe to World
War II yeah clearly led to at least for
Generations being like no like we don't
need War like Europe seems to be anytime
there's like a uh geopolitical unrest
Europe seems to be very quick to be like
no no you don't trust me you don't want
to do this you don't yeah please don't
not enough obviously but I mean France
was very against the Iraq War and stuff
like that right but America escaped a
large part of the devastation so I think
America is like Europe's four Crux if
you're a Harry Potter fan
good reference
but yeah it's like uh like we were
living on we're the grossest part of
Europe is still yeah
one of the theories about the US is that
we have this fantastic home court
advantage of being in the Western
Hemisphere and you know immediately to
the north of you is Canada or you know
relatively peaceful you know and then
Mexico and like you know like it's tough
to get be invaded by you know a foreign
entity look how hard D-Day was yeah and
that was just the English Channel right
right
um and also we had free real estate
forever right so anytime you had trouble
like hey uh the Italians are being
persecuted just go west white gold and
now we run out of land yeah it's like we
can't just give people land anymore
right we're gonna have to like address
our problems right
yeah and it's it's so I think there is a
little bit of uh you know and a lot of
our con I don't know Americans also have
through our our film and television have
really glorified
violence and War and stuff and like you
know and and so there's a little bit of
a Romanticism of being a soldier and
going off and fighting but
you know yeah
well this is a this is a feel-good
podcast is this normally what your
podcasts are like yeah it's kind of uh
okay
uh yeah I mean I think uh
we we can't fix it I mean yeah everyone
that's existing now has had a violent
past and they're all goals
the Romans and all that yeah it's just
like do we want to I don't think we want
I think we still want to conquer and
take over right which is uh becoming
obsolete
uh and we just have to sort of enjoy the
Finer Things in life we can't just enjoy
winning World War II you know storm to
the beaches and that kind of visceral
Joy I think is uh
it's too there's too much collateral
damage yeah the amount of joy that you
get get from it from yeah from
conquering yeah the the yeah
I mean and now that we're now that we
have nuclear weapons it's just like holy
cow you can't
you can't be in a pit you can't have two
superpowers get into a pissing contest
you know it's just
it's just not not to be messed with so
so what do you think about Ukraine
you can see me every Tuesday at the
House of Blues or or you can after I
answer this question no I'm kidding I'm
kidding uh I think it's incredibly sad I
think uh
I think there's something talk about
it's interesting that you would ask this
question
I think we can draw analogies to Putin
and Kanye of sort of like Putin being a
billionaire and board and already having
at one point cemented his legacy
and then I think almost like you know
what I really believe in this sort of
like uh Russian beliefs that of manifest
destiny and and we should uh we should
own the Ukraine and like
and talk about like I mean talk about a
guy
you know it is interesting that you
would ask her talk about a guy just like
Kanye who just [ __ ] his legacy down the
toilet yeah
I mean the guy could have rode off into
the sunset with this you know I mean he
was a billionaire uh President of Russia
who you know helped their economy and
stuff and it's like but now all that
Goodwill is just down the drain by a
senseless Invasion so
uh not a fan how about you it's crazy
that he's doing that in 2022 right I
mean I think that he sees where Russia
is headed yeah and he sees that they
don't have a very good future yeah and
he's this is a desperation move you
think yeah but I think it's only hurting
it because they had to freeze their
stock market and they can't you know and
and their oligarchs are running for the
hills you know and it's it's it's
actually messing up their economy you
know yeah it's definitely a hard thing
but yeah I think that the cards that
they were dealt with dealt weren't very
good and I think it's right large part
of that is America just yeah like we won
the Cold War and then we just kept
[ __ ] with them right kept taking from
them
I think
the reason why Putin is in charge is
because they had no other alternative
But to answer violence with violence
right
um but uh yeah I mean if Russia was
allowed to enter the World Market after
the Cold War and if they were given a
fair shot
um I don't think this would have
happened but we don't live in a world
where we're kind to other countries
right I mean America is a country that
will take from other countries as much
as possible
I mean uh like what we did to Guatemala
or Brazil or you know Latin American
countries that we it's put in a puppet
dictator for like bananas yeah
yeah
um but I mean my country of South Korea
uh is doing good now yeah so that's like
the one country that wasn't too heavily
[ __ ] with right South Korea was helped
a lot but
right it's a rare exception it's like
the the one country that benefited from
American imperialism right right
foreign
yeah all true but
you know I think they're also like we
were in a cold war with Russia and the
idea yeah you're never going to get to
the end and win a cold war and show
Mercy you know yeah you're not going to
show and then help another nation-state
build up their economy right like talk
about a zero-sum game like you're you're
trying to
it's certainly seen as like well if if
we're on top then everyone else should
be on the bottom and vice versa you
don't want them to become a superpower
and then you're a secondary power like
it so there is this and I'm not saying
that I'm saying that that's more like
the US probably mentality you know yeah
so they I mean that's I think that's the
problem is we can't just want to be on
top maybe we need to uh
you know like live in a more U.N type
world or Sweden be like yeah we might
not be the best but our people are
surviving
there's not riots in the street yeah
um but like the cold war like that was
an instigated by Russia that was
instigated by America and we just didn't
want them to do what they were doing
which is like why not like yeah if they
want to do communism
like why are we so vehemently opposed to
that I think it's because it's a threat
to what we have here which is always it
um it would be such a violent change
from a free market economy
to you know communism although again
like and this has been the criticism
we're not truly free market right like
when George W Bush was president and we
had the 2008 financial meltdown they
were bailing out Banks like crazy like
you know and even George W bush and his
speech in the Rose Garden he goes now
while I'm all for the free market you
know
uh there are comes a time when you got a
bail people it's like so
you know it's it's it's it's it's kind
of a lie right
everyone's everyone's free every
Republican leader is a free market guy
until they need to do a bailout you know
and yeah I don't know you know it's just
nuts yeah I mean it's not a free market
it's uh Market that supports
billionaires yeah yeah that's the whole
goal of it right and billionaire
companies and yep yeah
what is it I've always wanted to be on a
communist talk radio
well I think it's like we were better
than feudalism back in 1776's right but
then we just sort of stopped right there
yeah we didn't give more freedoms to
more people we just were sort of like
yeah please
Kings we should get rid of kings and
just be rolled over by yeah oligarchs
yeah but it is a shame that like the US
has gotten so far into this
hyper capitalism always needing the
bottom line to shake out well like
corporate bailouts corporations not
paying taxes like I'll never understand
that like GE does 12 billion in income
and they can't pay any taxes and Apple
you know this U.S company in in
California
all of a sudden they got a PO Box in
Ireland and now they're not paying taxes
like
[ __ ] give us a couple million you know
something like yeah you know
it's like uh yeah we could uh
if you want to be a part of a country
that's good you gotta pay for it yeah
um yeah so
I was uh
how's the scene in Chicago
what a seamless transition
corporate oligarchs to uh open mics
yeah the richest of the rich in America
and uh tell us about those
poverty-stricken open mikers in Chicago
they could really use a bailout yeah
they could use the bailout uh yeah I
think what I'm realizing now I've done
I've been sort of like traveled a little
bit participated in scenes or seen
scenes like
everywhere it's like New York Chicago I
did a month in San Francisco this year
and hearing you talk about Austin and
and other places it's like
I I just think they're all the same in
my opinion yeah I I've yet to meet
anyone who's like oh the local comedy
scene everybody builds everyone up and
they're so supportive and like you know
like no I I think it's just human nature
it's like
every comic I you know I don't know if
your listeners are all Comics or not but
like for those who aren't Comics who are
listening it's like
comedy's no different than anything else
I thought it would be
um I actually got into comedy to get out
of the Rat Race and now I just find
myself in a in a different Rat Race just
the rats are all calm the rats are funny
and
um
it's still a rat race right I mean you
got Headliners and features and hosts
and open mikers and
you know they're people who never seem
to graduate out open mic and and
uh the city is just a skin that you want
to
look at while you do comedy like would
you rather be you know having public
transit and all that or would you rather
yeah uh be in a smaller scene going to
go up once a week right that's a great
way to look at it yeah yeah it's like a
dressing on the outside yeah that's a
great way to look at it like yeah what
Skyline do you want to look at while you
tell your jokes you know yeah like what
kind of accent do you want do you want
to yeah have Heckle you yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
and like yeah because it's like I I will
say like I was in San Francisco for like
a month earlier this year just living
out there and like that's a great scene
they've got clubs they've got punch line
they've got cops they've got
um The Improv in San Jose
uh which I think you're gonna be at in
December yeah something right that'll be
awesome
um and you know it's like it's just
stuff like that it's cool it's um
it's they've got a scene right clubs and
features and Headliners and I'm sure
their own shared drama
um I it's like anything you know
yeah
basically take those human elements and
put them in any scene and I think you've
got it I mean Chicago rocks right like
like we have
fantastic independent shows
uh tight ship comedy I run that one I
run a show at the House of Blues that's
Chicago Comedy Club there's comedians
you should know those are probably like
some of the best independent shows
um but then we've got like clubs you
know Zanies of course
um
it's the comedy bar I feel like uh
Hans where am I going with this I don't
know basically it's the same element
yeah wherever you go the scenes yeah the
scene yeah I mean it's really the people
yeah in the scenes and who you get along
with and how you happen to have met and
what kind of relationships you can form
yeah but uh yeah I think it's uh
it's I think you should move around
until you find one that fits you or
learn how to fit into whatever scene you
happen to be in but right yeah I mean
it's hard to move around unless you live
in a van and then find the best scene
for you yeah is that how you do you feel
like Austin like you've when you found
awesome did you feel like it was the
best scene for you or do you feel like
at the time just because the [ __ ]
pandemic and everyone was all [ __ ]
yeah uh shut down and
uh yeah it was uh I I loved La I mean
honestly I probably wouldn't have stayed
in Austin unless I had gotten the
opportunities that I did yeah which have
been great so I probably
um
I I think it's a great scene I think
there's a lot of great energy there
but uh especially since I was living in
a van at the time I don't think I could
stay in Texas during the summer months
right unless there was a really good
reason too but like because it was so
hot yeah yeah
as human and it's hard to live in a van
that you can't open the door
I don't know what helps
yeah yeah I had an AC unit I plugged it
into my friend's house and I'm staying
at nice yeah and I made it work I was in
my own little room that must have [ __ ]
saved you just uh I feel like when
people like frame you though on podcasts
I I think I I listened to a couple
podcasts before working with you this
weekend like
you were people frame it in a way like
wow he went from living in a van to
opening with for Joe Rogan like you did
choose to live in them it wasn't like
you got fired from your job did heroin
and your parents kicked you out of your
house right that was like a yuppie it's
like a witch kid white kid uh Choice
it's like a tourist yeah just doing it
for fun yeah but it is sort of a crazy
move to make and not a move that a lot
of people are willing to make so it took
a level of dedication oh a thousand
percent I'm sure threw out all the
respect in the world like you basically
were like I wanna to go so hard at
comedy that I'm gonna avoid rent and
live in a van like I don't think I could
do that you know so kudos to you I mean
I don't know if it was my love of Comedy
or my hatred of myself
it's like I don't deserve good things or
resentment of a landlord yeah I'm just
saying that if you wanted to be on Oprah
when she gets her show back or whatever
you write a book like you know from the
van to Rogan or something you know what
I'm saying like yeah just dip the part
in the beginning when he was living in
Bellevue Washington right right right
yeah like like living out here is hard
hard it's like
from the van to the creek in the cave
you know I don't know you know the creek
to the cave yeah
um but yeah it's uh it's us I don't
think that it should be I don't think
it's the best way to create comedy yeah
um I think it's an interesting way to
create comedy but I would rather have
like a Swedish
Society where people have basic
uh basic wages or like yeah food and
shelter and then if you want to do
whatever you dedicate yourself to it
then right that's the best way to make
art
yeah there is something to be said about
like I
I do wonder how much American creativity
is not capitalized on because so many
people are like well I have to have this
job to have this health insurance to pay
off my you know and to work to pay off
my student loan debt it's like I don't
know if you're gonna get a great
you know painter or writer if they're so
do you know what I'm saying like trapped
in that
you know
yeah I think uh
it's because we have all the loot of the
world we're the richest country so yeah
we can gloss over our imperfections with
just the amount of [ __ ] that we have
yeah and like Sweden is a great country
but they just don't have the same amount
of [ __ ] right so they just can't create
McDonald's or whatever because all the
loot of the world is not going to them
yeah I will say that there's something
in our culture that inherently does love
that kind of efficiency and mass
production and that that's our right
that's like your Henry Ford you know the
the the with the Model T it's like it's
like he was like he invents the assembly
line and then we just apply it to the
cheeseburger you know now we've applied
it to say Amazon or you know
yeah it's like uh making as much [ __ ] as
possible yeah and
not really worrying about the social
good or yeah quality of life yeah well I
mean you when you elected to go to to
Van life right like you're doing it must
have been
you must have then been like well I'm
not gonna buy a book I'll rent it from
the library or I borrow it from like you
must have like kept your possessions to
a minimum right
so you you had to make a conscientious
choice to sort of like you're like oh I
really want to read this book but you
wouldn't read the book you would just
you know what I'm saying yeah like
living in uh that kind of mindset of
doing
with less yeah
um yeah so are you are you saying like
that's not American or like I had to
forgo that kind of mindset no I wasn't
even commenting on it so much it's just
curious about like see like if I buy buy
a book now I'll just put on my bookshelf
like I've got enough space or whatever
like but van life like you must have
been like [ __ ] what am I gonna do with I
borrowed four books this you know what
I'm saying like they're in the way you
can't you can't be as decadent as you
were before right
I think it's good because uh you really
can't uh read four books at once but if
you do finish one book and you have
another book right there it's just a
little more convenient you just have to
be a little more conscious when you're
living in a van to just be like I need
this I'm going to go out of my way to
get this and that just sort of changes
your relationship right to stuff right
like just having more isn't necessarily
better like like the Primitive cultures
that are just
happy with what they have and yeah they
know how to use like everything like a
seashell and stuff yeah well there's
such a I I I've dabbled in I think I
told you this before the podcast like I
do a little bit of the financial
Independence Community which is really
like live simply and try to save a lot
so you can have some
some Independence and you know if you
don't like a job you can quit it go to
another job because you've maybe got
some money in the bank account or
whatever like it's that kind of thing
it's like don't you don't need to buy
the latest greatest all the time so I do
a little bit of that and it's like um
yeah you just start to realize like
really really I need more than anything
I need a good night's sleep and then you
know some food the next day but you've
got the clothes on your back you know
what I'm saying like it's I think we
tend to complicate it with like oh I
gotta have that big house and the big
ring and the big and the cars and the
well you get confused with what you need
and what you want right you're like I
need to have this book yeah and you're
like well
overall that's not efficient it'll take
up this amount of cubic centimeters
right
uh
um and yeah it's just uh it's just you
just have a more clearer understanding
of your life and what you need and stuff
yeah yeah do you but see you kind of
went into the van like out of like
wanting to do comedy slash hating
yourself you know like writing uh the
job market and yeah economy so was it
was that like a New York City move like
if you hadn't been based if you had been
like wanting to go do comedy and say
somewhere else maybe more affordable
like the Midwest you wouldn't have done
van life do you was that like a
conscientious like New York City like
all right if I'm gonna try a new comedy
in New York City well which came first
the desire to move to New York City and
that mentality to move to the best city
yeah or
was living in the best city motivated to
to live that way yeah because I wanted
to move to the best city and give myself
the best chance yeah that I would do
something like that so I think I had
that mentality before I moved to New
York yeah and then just to utilize New
York to the utmost of my ability yeah uh
it seemed like the smart choice for me
just because I was like and that's kind
of mindset at that time but I think also
like
uh in New York living in a van has the
most upsides to it because I could right
before go like four thousand dollars in
rent right whereas in Oklahoma I'm only
like saving a thousand bucks
of rent so
let me ask you this let's say someone
after one of your shows hunts like walks
up to you and it's like Hans like I
really want to do comedy I want to I
want to break into comedy like what
would your advice to them be get advance
I don't think everyone should have a van
I don't love cars I don't love sleeping
on the road yeah I think uh what I love
is doing what I love and just not having
any [ __ ] where I have to pretend to
enjoy things
or just sit through uh my life and wait
for it to be over to start my life I
think like just getting rid of any time
where your soul is being slowly [ __ ]
at your feet away yeah I think it's the
best thing to do I think that our souls
are our spirit our joy of life is such a
resource that is so it's so uh
commonplace to squander that yeah uh
respecting that in yourself is uh
is an important step to take to if you
want to do an art form where you're
going to be expressing yourself and
Katie yeah
yeah because if you don't love yourself
or if you don't respect yourself enough
to give yourself your own life and how
are you going to respect an audience of
other people right
and be like I want you guys to feel good
like when you don't even do that to
yourselves nice
it's a nice thought I uh
yeah that's awesome so your whole you're
sort of like Mantra or whatever like
ethos is kind of like you're basically
like
like you're kind of living for you but
not so selfishly like you're hedonistic
like you're like you're just like I
don't want [ __ ] in my life you cut
the crap out of your life yeah
which for you was like a job yeah yeah
it's great like I'm bad at it yeah it's
not like I had a choice I wasn't like
killing it in the office world and I was
like this is bad right I just I couldn't
do it I just uh I operate on this
way where like I'm either going to be
completely honest or a complete [ __ ]
psychopath so either I could destroy the
rainforest and right take money from
lower middle class people like the
subprime mortgage crisis or I could just
be completely honest right all the time
that was our exit oh well UTA is similar
for the yeah other one well there's some
good pods for you
sorry I was I was we were potting so
hard
I missed a turn can't play hardcast hard
yeah I know you mean I thought about it
like like if I wasn't a comic would I go
full psycho and because there is
something human about like wanting to
thrive like what I go full psycho in my
corporate job and try to ascend the
ranks and run a corporation yeah the
people that do that are just so
psychotic yeah yeah like for our whole
human history being inauthentic or like
doing things that you don't know why
you're doing it is bad for your survival
so all our instincts are telling us that
you're gonna die if you're not doing
this but yet that's the people that
succeed the most right
so it's uh the people that succeed the
most in a broken Society are not the
people that you want to be right right
yeah
yeah but I mean that's that's you
literally echoed the same thought but in
a different way like look at look at the
best among you and if they're unhealthy
then that's indicative of your uh
Society it's like a sick Kanye or a sick
uh president you know like a it's like
it's not good you know
yeah
yeah
it's uh yeah it's
it's hard to have to come up with your
own structure for life on your own yeah
it'd be better if we lived in a culture
that could provide that for us and that
we could build on top of that right but
it's also creates interesting people
because everyone has to come out with a
life Solution on their own so everyone's
unique
but I mean how how many grandmas have to
starve in the projects for us to produce
a LeBron James yeah is that worth it
right
yeah and and how much value is a LeBron
James he might have crushed his field
but how much value is a Superstar
athlete bringing to all of society and
that's not I'm not going to live Brown I
know he does good stuff but like you
know at the end of the day it's just
entertainment so yeah I mean that's what
we can all provide is just emotional uh
reinforcement and strength to people but
you also have to make things and you
know uh provide basic services for
people right
those services are all stripped bare to
make as much profit or to cut down an
overhead
so I mean until you can get everyone to
be on board with like just helping
people it just right one extra social
worker is uh isn't gonna really do that
much impact
gotcha
so how did you like how old were you
when you think you arrived at this
philosophy of like do you like like when
you told your parents you were going to
live in a van like did they
did they have a meltdown where they like
Hans you can't like no like or were they
like you do you well I was uh I got
fired from my startup job and I moved in
with my parents yeah and then they were
like what are you gonna do with your
life and then I just started doing
comedy and they're like why are you
going out late at night I'm really
concerned are you doing drugs again and
I was like yes and also but I found
comedy I found something to do and they
were like oh at least you found
something thank God that sounds like a
an improviser joke like are you doing
drugs again yes and uh
yes and uh I do comedy I got an essay
your parents yeah oh thank you so much
any of Hans Hans Kim's fans who's been
listing uh my name is Chris trying I'm a
Chicago comic look me up sometime and uh
thanks for listening Instagram Facebook
uh it's Chris troney yeah
thanks for having me yeah thanks for
doing it